estos buzos tunecinos se dirigen hacia
el hundimiento su misión es comprobar el
estado del casco del barco petrolero el
buque que enarbola el pabellón de guinea
ecuatorial' se hundió el sábado frente
al golfo de gabes en el sureste de túnez
mientras cruzaba el mediterráneo de
egipto a malta los siete tripulantes
fueron rescatados pero su cargamento de
750 toneladas de diesel hace temer un
posible derrame de petróleo
si una fuga contamina este mar no
tendremos a donde ir porque ya sólo
podemos pescar en un pequeño perímetro a
tu mujer la ministra de medio ambiente
de túnez estuvo en el lugar y trató de
enviar un mensaje tranquilizador
es una carga de diésel es muy diferente
porque es mucho menos peligroso y tiende
a evaporarse bastante rápido y atendamos
a ese vapor hacia jaquismo
cocer nolito si no ha habido
filtraciones todavía aloja xtrail que el
led aunque habitamos en yapeyú descrito
problema las autoridades creen que la
situación está bajo control esperan
poder evitar que la problemática avance
instalando barreras anticontaminación
flotantes alrededor del perímetro del
hundimiento la ong fondo mundial para la
naturaleza está preocupada porque esta
zona de pesca sustenta a cientos de
marineros tunecinos además ya está muy
debilitada por varios episodios de
contaminación química pero también
petrolera